BRIAN:  NEW YORK CITY MAYOR BILL
DEBLASIO CELEBRATING THE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS OF THE
PANDEMIC IN A HOMETOWN HEROS
PARADE YESTERDAY BUT SOME OF THE
CITIES FIRST RESPONDERS SAY
THE EVENT SCALED BACK BECAUSE OF
THE HEAT WAS NOT WHAT THEY WERE
HOPING FOR HERE TO EXPLAIN 13
YEAR VETERAN OF NEW YORK CITY'S
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
PARAMEDIC, LEONNA ESPINOL.
WHAT IS YOUR COMPLAINT ABOUT
YESTERDAY'S VERY HOT CELEBRATION
>> GOOD MORNING SO MY COMPLAINT
ABOUT YESTERDAY'S CELEBRATION IS
IT'S A CLEAR SIGN THAT WE NEEDED
TO BE CELEBRATED, THAT WE PUT IN
A LOT OF WORK.
THE FIRST RESPONDERS AND ALL OF
THE ESSENTIAL WORKERS, BUT
GIVING US A PARADE JUST SHINES
LIGHT ON HOW MUCH WE NEED A
RAISE, WE NEED MORE MONEY.
THE THANK YOU AND THE PRAISE AND
THE PARADE IS NICE BUT IT JUST
DOESN'T PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE
AND ALLOW US TO TAKE CARE OF OUR
FAMILIES.
BRIAN:  THEY DIDN'T GIVE YOU A
DAY OFF TO ATTEND RIGHT?
>> NO DEFINITELY NOT.
BRIAN:  SO YOU LOSE A DAYS
PARADE TO GO TO A PARADE IN
HONOR OF YOU.
WHAT'S IT BEEN LIKE FOR YOU IN
THE LAST YEAR IN PARTICULAR?
>> WORKING THROUGH COVID WAS
VERY DIFFICULT FOR  MANY REASONS
, DIFFICULT BECAUSE WE
SAW MORE DEATHS THAN WE HAD EVER
SEEN BEFORE AND DIFFICULT
BECAUSE SOME OF US WERE
SEPARATED FROM OUR FAMILIES, IT
WAS DIFFICULT FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T
SEPARATE FROM THEIR FAMILIES,
THEY RISKED PUTTING THEIR
FAMILIES IN DANGER.
THEY LOST FAMILY MEMBERS, YOU
KNOW, IT WAS VERY MENTALLY AND
EMOTIONALLY AND PHYSICALLY
STRESSFUL FOR US AS A WHOLE, NOT
JUST FOR MYSELF.
BRIAN:  IF YOU WANT TO SEE
APPRECIATION, SHOW US IN THE
PAY, NOT WITH A PARADE.
>> SHOW US IN THE PAY, NOT WITH
THE PARADE, ALLOW US TO BE ABLE
TO TAKE CARE OF OUR FAMILIES
WITHOUT HAVING TO WORK 80 HOURS
A WEEK.
YOU CAN'T TAKE CARE OF YOUR
FAMILY AND NOT BE THERE FOR THEM
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO BE AT WORK
SO MUCH.
BRIAN:  ABSOLUTELY, I KNOW COPS
HAVE THE SAME THING I GOT TO GO
HOME BUT STAY AWAY FROM MY
FAMILY BECAUSE I HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT I WAS EXPOSED TO A
MYSTERIOUS VIRUS WE STILL DON'T
KNOW WHERE IT CAME FROM.
THE MAYORS OFFICE WAS ASKED TO
RESPOND TO THE CRITICISM THEY
SAY GATHERING FOR ESSENTIAL
WORKERS THROUGH THE DARKEST
TIMES, IT WAS THE LEAST WE COULD
DO FOR OUR HOMETOWN HEROS THIS
PARADE WAS ABOUT THEM BUT
THEY DIDN'T GIVE YOU A DAY OFF
SO THEY HAVEN'T INCREASED YOUR
PAY.
WE APPRECIATE YOU AND I HOPE YOU
FEEL A LITTLE OF THAT BECAUSE
YOU CERTAINLY DESER